Netflix's stranger things has captivated
audiences with a satisfying throwback to
classic 80s paranormal thrillers but how
this modern classic actually happened
here's a look at the untold truth of
stranger things super duffer brothers
twins matt and ross Dafa the
writer/director duo who created the show
showed an early interest in filmmaking
experimenting with home movies as early
as third grade they pursued their
passion by studying film at Chapman
University the first movie was hidden a
horror film which didn't receive wide
release but it did catch the eye of M
night Shyamalan who hired them to work
on his series wayward Pines that
experience gave the duffer's the start
they needed to pitch their own series
with the help of producers Dan Cohen and
Shawn Levy Netflix eventually bought the
show but only after it was rejected by
at least 15 other networks strong Island
stranger things takes place in Hawkins
Indiana but the duffer's originally
wanted to play with the concept of a
waterside setting specifically Montauk
New York the region's real-life history
may have inspired their story legend has
it the town's camp hero Air Force Base
was a lot like MKULTRA in very
disturbing ways including serving as the
site of room and government experiments
with mind control on kidnapped children
Georgia on my mind stranger things was
filmed in the Atlanta Georgia area which
is also home to a number of television
and film productions so that was just
bound to be a location crossover or to
the Belwood quarry where fake wills body
is found and mike is bullied into cliff
diving was the same site seen in The
Walking Dead's first season and the
hunger games movies your next Hollywood
inspired trip destination is just me
booked font of wisdom most of stranger
things pop-culture references were put
in on purpose and the title art font is
no exception it's an altered version of
we at which was used on a slew of
classic Stephen King book covers
including but not limited to Cujo
Salem's Lot
firestarter Pet Sematary misery and the
stand the typeface which was designed by
Edie Bangui art was also popularized in
1978 and also has been seen in the
openings for films like Star Trek
generations and Star Trek first contact
80s cinema school finding the right
child star thought stranger things was
important because even though there are
cast members with higher billing the
show's heart revolves around the kids
the duffer's auditioned nine hundred and
six boys and three hundred and seven
girls for the roles using scenes from
stand by me when they finally settled on
the cast they were sent home with
instructions to watch films like
poltergeist and The Goonies to get a
sense of the look and feel of the show
to come
clearly it paid off on the first day of
filming they shot the first Dungeons &
Dragons session that starts the series
the duffer's told Entertainment Weekly
our boys flew through the scene
effortlessly and energetically and the
chemistry was electric they felt like
they'd known each other the whole lives
other than when we sold the show to
Netflix this was the single biggest
moment for stranger things buzz cut baby
Milly Bobby Brown who turned in stunning
work as the super-powered eleven didn't
know she'd have the share of her locks
until she'd already won the role she
eventually came around to the idea after
being shown an image of Charlize Theron
buzzcut in Mad Max fury road she was
also encouraged by an old pic of co-star
Winona Ryder who sported a pixie cut in
a younger days sort of a choice showed
you my school and I said I don't know
show me so I thought like you know
Winona looks cool and back in the day
with you know the pixie cut and I
thought maybe I could bring it back
channeling Meryl Streep when her two
Ryder a legend of the 80s herself thanks
to Heather's and Beetlejuice was one of
the first casting picks for stranger
things but when she was approached about
the show she had no idea what streaming
was
and little TV experience for her
characters look though she found
inspiration in Meryl Streep's
performance in Silkwood which was
released the same year as the shows
events her hair in the show was
something of a tribute to the
oscar-winning star Stephen King is a fan
as one of the biggest inspirations for
stranger things
author Stephen King's praise of the show
is worth a lot the author wrote on
Twitter that when he watched the show it
was like watching Steve King's greatest
hits in a good way and graded the
program and a for pure fun interestingly
enough Finn wolf hud who plays Mike
Wheeler in the show will star in another
big Stephen King inspired property the
upcoming big-screen adaptation of it
which will circle the duffer's tried in
vain to direct years ago thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what you want to see in
stranger things season 2